Zach Lieberman
(New York)
I try to bring happiness to everyone and make people laugh.
I try to create an unusual moment for everyone.
I am studying art.
Learning oil painting and printmaking
Animation is always my hobby
Animation can make things alive, I like this concept
And coding makes things come alive
I am fascinated by this idea.
Many of the projects I participated in involved motion and drawing
"As long as you can draw it, you can make it."
What is the significance of marking?
Is it really important to draw a line on a piece of paper?
It’s like saying “Go here”
I often ask questions about "what if..."
What would an automatic line expansion look like?
You can only get the answer by coding.
I think we need a poetic culture.
I use "poetic calculations" to describe our work.
For me, poetry is to arrange the right words in the proper order.
The same is true for code
The number of these words is extremely streamlined
Are some very specific words that allow the computer to perform specific operations.
What often happens now is
We enter the museum in a curvilinear way through unconventional means
The upcoming next generation museum curator
Will gradually learn this treatment and these tools
And become part of this community
So as we grow together
This art form will increasingly be recognized by the art world.
A lot of my work is coding but I need to build things
I will spend a lot of time looking for materials
Such as used speakers and components
And sometimes this is really useful for getting inspiration.
Our surroundings are full of data
One of the phenomena is when we enter the taxi
I don't know what the radio will play.
May be a radio talk show or a sports show, or a Senegalese music
My DevArt proposal is called "Playing the World"
This is a keyboard you just press a note
The system will find this note in the audio stream that is played globally in real time.
These projects always originate from a crazy idea
One of my responsibilities is to trouble myself.
Then try to free yourself from trouble.
After being appointed
You will be working side by side with Zach Lieberman of the Barbican Arts Centre in London.
The art of code creation